representative Lauren brobert getting
frisky have you ever been have you ever
gotten a movie theater uh hand job or a
Broadway I've theater hand job or blow
job I me it's going to get uh the first
time I ever touched a woman's pubic hair
was was during Batman and Robin when it
was in theaters in Aurora Colorado in
Aurora at the Seven Hills movie theater
Jesus with the girl I was dating but
this is how stupid I was most of the
time you go in through the top of the
pants it was the summer I went up the
leg like a true wow 13-year-old boy
interesting I had no idea what I was
doing and then I remember that was the
first time I ever touched someone else's
pubic hair and I was like whoa you know
in the in the theater through the leg in
the theater through the leg completely
blew it probably could have gotten a lot
more had I entered properly was she like
what's happening yeah yeah she cheated
on me that summer with two other guys
who both like knew what they were doing
so Jesus Christ that was one of those
things where you're like I [__] up I
[__] up but seeing Lauren bobert do
that you're like oh that's a clear you
just got divorced move cuz you know
what's funny about watching like elected
officials is like George Santos is from
Long Island he just lies we're all liars
so you know what kind of what kind of
lie he's going to come with absolutely
and I know Lauren bobert's coming from
the Western Front the other side of the
mountains where it's like Garfield
County you know where you're like sure
there's Aspen but then there's also
Glennwood Springs and there's like it's
it's not all Aspen and
it's a lot of like small little towns
where they're like they shoot guns in
order to show Joy they show that they're
happy yeah and she was going in I mean
she's giving him kind of it looks like
she's going in she's going in my
favorite part about all this my favorite
part about all this is when you find out
it's a first date right cuz that's third
date totally fine a great point the
first date you're like she got into it
yeah that means because this is the show
yeah so they they clearly got drinks
probably went to dinner right and then
headed down to the bule performing arts
center right they were probably you know
in loo downtown probably having a little
and then they go and she's just ripped
she's hammered she's ripping a vape yeah
pregnant lady asks her to stop she's
like shut up [__] right and then he's
just fondling those tits cuz he knows
he's like if I get her liquored up and
we go to Beetle Juice the musical
there's no way nothing gets this girl
hotter right than a Michael Keaton
vehicle's not even in it anymore Beetle
Juice to musical just going to get her
in the right frame of mind unfortunately
Mr Mom doesn't Mr Mom the musical
doesn't open for five months does not
work I could take her to Beetle Juice
yeah and my dick's coming out there's
got to be not the people next to them
but the people on the opposite side of
the aisle just being like is that woman
grabbing that dude's dick what's funny
is apart from it being Lauren bobbert
there's definitely just people in the
theater going like who's this yeah piece
of [__] yeah and the reveal the reveal
that it's your representative you know
remember back in uh when they when they
did commercials for movies where they
would do the audience reaction as they
left where they were like best time of
the summer if they would have taken
those people and been like did you know
that was Lauren bobbert they would have
been like holy [__] like if they would
have grabbed that blast radius of who
she was around yeah it's just people
being like we had no idea there was a
horor house operating at Beetle Juice to
musical I don't know she must have
walked from cax it was it was incredible
CU you know that no one knew until the
News That's Right ex maybe even a couple
people at the theater maybe knew right
but most of those people around her are
like who is this [__] in this dress just
a drunk person acting inappropriately in
public which is not rare now if I could
have informed them yeah and ining them
that it was Lauren bobbert probably
would have been about third on the list
yeah cuz what I first would have done
was gone now that woman's 36 and they go
okay and I go she's a grandma and they
go
okay and then you go Lauren bober they
like holy [__] you what's fun about her
is that you know she is a wild woman
like her husband and her used to get in
brawls the cops would come which I mean
dude you know honestly the Colorado
blood in me oh yeah understands voting
for that oh yeah you want someone who's
gonna defend your state the way she
defends her car from her husband with a
bag yeah I like someone where it's like
oh you really are like a Rihanna song
and what's funny yeah the whole thing is
what's funny about her is like you know
she had no interest in politics she was
working in a bar some bar called
shooters or something she was her bar it
was her bar she owned the bar yeah and
she was like this is what I'm about and
then somehow she became a congresswoman
I
honestly I get it yeah because
13-year-old me yeah if I'm making up a
woman to jerk off to that's it I'm
watching all these action movies I'm
like she's got a Laura Lauren crof a
Tomb Raider gun on her leg Yeah she's
just you know not taking [__] she'll
fight right by your side then you find
out she's just fast and loose out of
she's [__] in the Theater which by
the way I would have much rather my mom
made me go to Joseph in the tech amazing
technol dream coat yeah in that theater
yeah when I was like 11 right if I would
have been there I would have been like
I'm a I'm a theater I'm a theater nerd
oh yeah no if you would watch Lauren
bobber jerk someone off during [__]
Beetle Juice Beetlejuice you would have
been like we're never not going to the
theater I love the Arts right I love the
Arts more funding for the Arts no I mean
that's that's amazing that she did that
get up the TMZ where she responds with
because they did catch her yeah yeah and
what I like about her is she's just kind
of like hey now the guy that she's
[__] own like a gay bar he owned a
bar where they have drag drag kns he's a
he's a Democrat yeah and I love that
she's like wow [__] she had such a but
it's also people that are surprised
about it she's like no no no I'm a [__]
I don't care who the I'll sleep with
anyone it doesn't matter you could have
been Al qada I would have sucked them
off in the back right so here here we go
this is Lauren bber from I know it's you
know been a rough week what has it been
uh you know it's um it's always hard
whenever um there's gravity put on the
voters I'm here to provide levity and
lift burdens off of people so hold on
pause this already she's already got hot
she's already got hot girl giving a book
report she's in front of the class cuz
you know she wants to walk up and go
like [__] happens guy had a
hog
with that shoulder showing and that
Colorado hat that she looks like she
bought at DIA she's not a badl looking
woman she's hot she's hot and she
probably walked across the street being
like ah you suck some you [__] some and
you lose some right but see now she's
got to like run that back it's very
interesting the gravity she might as
well given tent fingers she's like the
gravity of the
situation this is like when my parents
would be like hey there was $100 on the
Manel it's not there anymore I'd be I'd
be really High I'd be like well you know
uh the spatial relationship between
objects and honestly with inflation and
everything going on right now I think we
can understand you know big Banks do way
worse yeah right let's see this Lauren
Boer what has it been uh you know it's
um it's always hard whenever um there's
gravity put on the voters I'm here to
provide levity and lift burdens off of
people so anytime that they're carrying
mine it's something that you kind of
feel deep inside but ultimately all
future date nights have been cancelled
and um I learned to check party
affiliations uh before you go on a date
uh but all in all um you know it was a
it was mostly a lovely time and you know
I've taken responsibility for my actions
um would love to know how the the
musical ended and I encourage people to
go and see it but um yeah it it was a
great time back in the district seeing
voters and uh so how are the vo is
taking it how are the vo is taking it
right now are they understanding at this
moment yeah there's a lot of folks who
are certainly understanding um and they
understand that it was part of my they
understand it was hot as
[__] there's a lot of people draging off
to this right now all over the world
there's you know what surprising is our
response to Sarah Palin was an immediate
porn parody right starring Lisa an it
was almost immediate right it's
incredible yeah that there is already
not a porn parody called like
congresswoman in in the theater it's
it's it I would say that it's if it's
not already there it's in the works yeah
they're filing absolutely in the works
in the valley there's a studio converted
into a fake theater right now yeah it's
just if you're if you're not doing that
it's wasted time what are you do it they
give you this it's wasted time I mean
she is that's what's going to bring the
world together is more porn parodies of
politics politics I want the hunter
Biden crack [__] [__] tape
I want the Lauren bobert theater one
theater dick par I want uh marjerie
Taylor green and a CrossFit you know
those like muscle porns she's like a
she's like a crossfit mom yeah and it's
just like a a super Jack guy on steroids
well this is like Colorado being from
Colorado you know it's like a little
wild and the people that live there like
to feel it's a little wild so this kind
of fits into what people do it's exactly
what it is it is it is mini malls built
on Stolen land that's right and it's
it's your only three generations removed